[موسيقى]
عندما حاصر جنكيز خان مدينه بخاره عجز عن
اقتحامها فكتب لاهلها ان من وقف في صف
المغول فهو امن وافق صف على الرضوخ وتسليم
المدينه للمغول خوفا من بطشه
فكتب لهم جنكيز خان مجددا ان اعنت مون على
قتال الارهابيين الذين رفضوا السلام
واصروا على المقاومه نوكم امر بلدكم ونمكن
من الحكم والسلطه تجند الخونه والجبناء
وحاربوا ابناء شعبهم بدعم من جيش المغول
عن بعد فغلبوا المقاومه لتبدا القصه
الحقيقيه او خلاصتها دخل المغول بخاره
وذبحوا عملائهم بعد ان سحبوا منهم السلاح
وقال جنكيز خان لهم مقولته الشهيره لو كان
يؤمن جانبكم لما غدرتم باخوان لاجلنا ونحن
الغرباء الذين جئنا لاذلال
واحتلال الى
العناوين جنود لواء جولاني يحتفلون بسحبهم
من ارض
المعركه اسيره مفرج عنها الفلسطينيون لا
ينكسرون
سيعودون جندي عائد من الحرب يتبول لا
اراديا ويكاد يقتل
زوجته وزيره المراه الاسرائيليه تريد رؤيه
غزه محاطه
بالجثث القطاع في قلب المجاعه ومجلس الامن
مجلس
الامنيات مؤرخ يهودي اسرائيل ستنتهي خلال
عقد او ثلاثه
بالاكثر ميلاد المسيح عليه السلام يغيب
احتفاله عن مهدي
[موسيقى]
الميلاد مرحبا هذه الحفله الصاخبه التي
اقامها واء جولاني نخبه مقاتلي جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليست بمناسبه تحقيقه
نصرا نوعيا ميدانيا على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بل هو فرح
استثنائي بموافقه حكومه تل ابيب وقياده
جيشها على سحبه من قطاع غزه حيث بات
جولاني مهددا بالانقراض
يقولون
جولاني اصبح جو هوم احلل يا جنرال بعد
تكبده خسائر كبيره في قتاله داخل قطاع غزه
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي سحب لواء جولاني
الاعلان جاء بعد 60 يوما من القتال ضد
حركه حماس وبعد يوم من اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي مقتل عشره جنود وضباط ثمانيه
منهم من الكتيبه 12 عش في اللواء اسرائيل
تقول ان جنود جولاني غادروا غزه لاعاده
تنظيم صفوفهم فيما اعلنت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه انه تم تدمير 720 اليه عسكريه
تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدء الهجوم
البري في ال 27 من اكتوبر الماضي كلام
المستشرق اليهودي موردخاي كيدار تسبب
بازمه للدعايه العسكريه الاسرائيليه عندما
قال ان حماس ستنتصر لان عقيده القتال
لديها اقوى الفتى افيخاي ادرعي افا بدا
وكانه يرد على الجد موردخاي كيدار ويتحدث
عن بطولات الهاربين من ارض المعركه الفرق
هو حضاره ووجود فابتل يسطرون يوميا ملاحم
بطوله دفاعا عن الوطن والبيت فقت لهم
الارهابيين يقتلون يعتدون يموتون في سبيل
شخص او مسلحه ليس لها اي اصل واي دين
فيسقط شهداؤنا لحمايه العائله والشعب
والسياده وهم يموتون من اجل فكره وهميه
وايديولوجية
هن من
غزه المراه عند المقاومه
الاسلاميه ملكه تقولان وتحذر من ان
الفلسطينيين سيعودون فراسهم لا ينحني
سيعودون مهما فعلنا
بهم
[موسيقى]
ي
ي الاسرى الاسرائيليون في غزه لا يخافون
المقاومه بل يخافون جيش الاحتلال الكلي
الاجرام بشهاده الاسيره الفرج عنها
ساهرون خماس الاسرى الاسرائيليون يشكلون
كنزا ثمينا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وهم احياء
لكن هل يريدهم نتنياهو موتى حتى يخفف
فاتوره التبادل مع المقاومه رجحت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه السبت مقتل خمسه اسرى لديها
جراء القصف الصهيوني المتواصل على قطاع
غزه واعلن ابو عبيده الناطق باسم كتائب عز
الدين القسام عن فقدان الاتصال بمجموع
عن خه اسرى نتيجه قصف الاحتلال قطاع غزه
هل يتعاطى جنود اسرائيل المخدرات في شوارع
غزه المفخخه عرض تمثيلي وصف بالمج من جنود
الانتصارات على
الباطون
كنا على سطح الارض وكنا ننادي يا عمو
ساعدنا يا عمو ساعدنا هذا عمو طلعنا من
تحت الانقاظ فاستشهدوا كل عيلتي اهل امي
واهل ابويا وخلاتي وعمتي ويعني كل اهل
يعني استشهدوا والله يرحمهم هم السابقون
ون اللاحقون اطفال غزه الذين يتحملون قصفا
جمعت له النار والحديد من الترسانات
الدوليه يتعاملون مع الموت والشهاده
بعباره الحمد لله هم السابقون ونحن
اللاحقون اما جندي الاحتلال افيخاي ليفي
فتلاحقه قذائف الاربجي
الفلسطينيه اللطيفه نسبيا بالمقارنه مع
صواريخ اسرائيل التدميريه تلاحقه في
منامات واليقظه ويعترف بان معارك غزه
جعلته مجنونا يشرب الخمره لينام يتبول لا
اراديا على نفسه والاهم ان انه يكاد يقتل
زوجته
ي
rp
امراه اسرائيليه تهاجم جنديا ناجيا من
لواء جولان بسبب قتلهم الاسرى فيعترف ان
جميع اصدقاه في جولاني قتلوا في الحرب على
غزه
يفي الامراض النفسيه والعقليه عدو غير
محسوب لجنود الاحتلال العائدين من غزه
وبعد امراض الجهاز الهضمي بكتيريا عنيده
تصيب جلودهم بالتعفن تقول السلطات الطبيه
الاسرائيليه انه بسبب احتكاكهم بتربه غزه
التي يفضل بعض المقاومين الفلسطينيين ان
يجوب سطحها وانفاقها حفاه بدون احذيه
بكتيريا قاتله وملوثات فطريه عنيده تتسلل
الى جنود داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي اثناء
قتالهم في قطاع غزه وتتسبب بمقتل عدد من
الجنود داخل المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
لاحظنا ذلك في اوساط الجنود الذين عادوا
مؤخرا من جبهه ال
الاحتكاك مع الارض والوحل هناك يؤدي
للتعرض للعديد من انواع البكتيريا وكذلك
لحالات العفن الامر لم يتوقف على الامراض
الجسديه بل امتد ايضا الى الازمات النفسيه
حيث نشرت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه نقلا عن
نتائج دراسات اظهرت ان
34% من الجنود يعانون من اعراض ما بعد
الصدمه بعد الهجوم نعيما جديده تقولها
الصحافه الاس اسرائيليه لجهاز الموساد لقد
اوهمت مونا لسنوات طويله ان محمد الضيف
مقعد لا يتحرك والفيديوهات اظهرت انه يمشي
على قدميه وانه بتسعه ارواح وفق التعليق
العبري فشل استخباراتي جديد يهز اسرائيل ل
تتفاجا بان قائد هيئه اركان كتائب القسامه
محمد الضيف يمشي اليوم على قدميه بعد ما
ظنت انها شلته
والزمتهه
احراج استخباراتي الم باسرائيل امس بعد
التقرير الذي كشفت عنه صحيفه معاريف
الاسرائيليه والذي يتحدث عن مقاطع فيديو
جديده حصل عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي لمحمد
الضيف وهو يمشي على قدميه ويعرج بشكل خفيف
بعد عده اسابيع من الحرب الكونيه على قطاع
غزه المحاصر من الجهات الخمس اسرائيل
تعتقل الدبدوب وحذاء يحيى السنوار رئيس
حركه حماس في قطاع غزه وتعثر كذلك في
عمليه بوليسيه او اعلاميه معقده على نسخه
ورقيه من الهويه الشخصيه لقائد كتائب
القسام الجنرال محمد الضيف كل التفاصيل مع
المراسله العبقريه للقناه الاسرائيليه
الثان
[موسيقى]
دل
واحده من شيخات الاستيطان تريد ان تقف في
جنوب غزه وتستطيع ان ترى البحر في شمالها
اطلاله بحريه فزه يهوديه برايها ويجب ان
تكون خاليه من العرب من المسلمين
والمسيحيين ومن
منازل يه
خ
قوات الاحتلال لم تتاخر على دانيلا مارست
اختصاصها وقامت بتفجير عشرات المنازل في
حي الشجاعيه مسجله بطوله جديده على
الباطون
ا
اما ماي غولان اين فهي وزيره تمكين المراه
الاسرائيليه وتطلب تمكينها من رؤيه غزه
محاطه بالجثث فما هو موقف الحركات
النسائيه في العالم من توزير امراه بهذه
الاوزار لوزاره
المراه
شركات بناء مدعومه من منظمات استيطان تبدا
ببيع بيوت على الخريطه مطله على مقابر
الابريه في غزه بيت على شاطئ غزه ليس حلما
اعلان لشركه هرها في الاسرائيليه احدى
شركات تطوير المستوطنات بيت على ارض لم
يجف الدم فيها بعد وتحاول هذه المنظمات
الاستيطانيه حشد دعم واسع النطاق لدى
الجمهور الاسرائيلي المرعوب من تكرار
سيناريو السابع من اكتوبر
[موسيقى]
الماضي الناس بتلم تحين على الارض ان ما
فيش اصلا منظمه الصحه العالميه لم تعد
تحذر من خطر المجاعه في غزه فقد اصبح
القطاع في قلب المجاعه والغزي يبيعون
ممتلكاتهم للحصول على الخبز الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو جوتيريس يشبع اهل
غزه
بالتصريحات اكثر من نصف مليون شخص اي ربع
عدد السكان يواجهون ما يصنفه الخبراء
بمستويات كارثيه من الجوع اربعه من كل
خمسه من اكثر الناس جوعا باي مكان في
العالم موجودون في غزه الممثل الاعلى
للشؤون الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيب
بوريل يلطم بدوره على الجائعين وهو يعلم
ان دولا من اتحاده الاوروبي شريكه في
محرقه غزه ومجاعات من خلال دعمها المالي
والمعنوي لعدوان اسرائيل 100% من سكان غزه
يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد في
حين يواجه ربع سكان القطاع جوعا ومجاعه
كارثيه وهذا امر غير مسبوق
حتى مجلس الامن صار جمعيه انسانيه تتمنى
الاماني بعد دعوته الى اتخاذ خطوات عاجله
لتوصيل المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه جامعه
الدول العربيه وفي خطوه متاخره منها تصف
خطوه مجلس الامن بالمتاح واعتبر الامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط دعوه المجلس الاممي للاعلان اعلان
الهدنه وفتح ممرات انسانيه الى جميع انحاء
قطاع غزه بالاجراء غير الكافي لوقف اله
الحرب الصهيونيه خاصه انه لا يتضمن وقفا
لاطلاق
النار المؤرخ الاسرائيلي ايلان بابي يرى
نهايه قريبه لاسرائيل فهل يعير نظاراته
لجبو المتصهين العربي الوهمي كمؤرخ تبدو
له النهايه نهايه اسرائيل تحتاج من 10 الى
عاما believe it i can see the indicators
i really see them clearly i can see the
indicators of the beginning of the end
but as an historian i know that the
beginning of the end can be a decade two
decades even three decades i'm afraid
that as an historian i'm allowed to say
it but as a human being i don't want to
say it you know i don't want to be there
for years in sit years
الحنان بيك حاخام يهودي اوري يؤكد من
منطلقه الديني اليهودي ان اسرائيل ستزول
ليش لانها متمرده على الله
يجيب
سيده امريكيه كانت تعتبر جهنم الوارده في
القران الكريم عقابا ظالما لكن ليس بعد
محرقه غزه فاسرائيل وحكومه واشنطن يستحقون
هذا العقاب الالهي بعد كل ما فعلوه في غزه
بحسب
رؤيتها
sk burn we will subtit skin so will
experience
the truly god has been almighty wise all
right so if you would have asked me six
months ago to read this ver and comment
on it i would have said something really
different i would have said that seems
pretty harsh but then i saw what's
happening
totin
upon
محمود الهباش مستشار الرئيس الفلسطيني
ماذا بينه وبين المصلين ليغادر المسجد
عندما اعتلى منبر الجمعه الهباس توعد
الاسبوع الماضي بمحاسبه المقاومه
الاسلاميه السلام
عل الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر احمد ابو شمله فلسطيني من غزه وموظف
في وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه استشهد بالقصف
الاسرائيلي الاعمى فوقف النواب الفرنسيون
حدادا عليه لكن رئيسه البرلمان الفرنسي
رفضت الوقوف فادارت للشهيد كتفها الايسر
رغم خدمته
جمهوريتها
العلمانيه رئيسه البرلمان الفرنسي ترفض
طلب الوقوف دقيقه صمت على روح السيد احمد
ابو شمله الموظف بالخارجيه الفرنسيه في
غزه منذ نحو ربع قرن يسقط احمد كضحيه
للقصف الاسرائيلي على رفح
هناك انتظر تحركا من الخارجيه الفرنسيه
لاجلاء مع عائلته كتله اليسار تعتبر ما
تعرض له احمد قبل وبعد مقتله امرا مشينا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لفرنسا ترب العيد وحرب الاباده
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه ما
توقفت كل مسيحيين في العالم بتجهز لاكبر
واهم عيد في السنه الا ارض الميلاد تشهد
اباده جماعيه ومجازر بحق شعبها الفلسطيني
كنا نضيء شجره الميلاد باضواء
اللماعه اما اليوم فنضيع بدماء الشهداء
التي نزفت من غزه العالم المسيحي يحتفل
بعيد ميلاد السيد المسيح الا في مهدي
ولاده المسيح عليه السلام
على امل ان يعود في السنه المقبله وقد
تخلت جيوش دول الغالبيه العظمى المسيحيه
عن دعم الاحتلال وعن فكر الذبح والتدمير
الشامل الذي ملا العالم قبورا منذ الحملات
الصليبيه الى اليوم مرورا بالحرب
العالميتين الاولى والثانيه مغاره الميلاد
مدمر تحت الانقاض هذه المره عمل فني نفذه
الفنان الفلسطيني طارق سلع امام كنيسه
المهد في بيت لحم بالضفه الغربيه لتسليط
الضوء على الوضع في قطاع غزه العالم كله
يحتفل بعيد الميلاد باستثناء بيت لحم هلا
نحن يوم الميلاد بحكي عن بيت لحم نحن عم
نحكي عن بيت لحم ممنوع يفوتوا على الكنيسه
يصلوا ببيت لحم مش عم بخترع هم مانعين انا
بنت الرعيه المسيحيه ببنان اريد من كاهنا
واحدا ان يتكلم ع ما يجري في بيت لحم او
انتم كلكم مش كهنه ومش مسيحيه وما
بتشرفونا من فوق لتحت ومن تحت لفوق بعد
بحتفل انه انه خلق المسيح ببيت لحم واهل
بيت لحم ممنوع يضو شمعه بالكنيسه وما بحكي
عنا بكنائس كلها قلي بوحده من عظاتك يا
ابونا باي كنيسه بلبنان احكيني شو عم صير
بكنيسه القيامه مره بزمانك بكنيسه المهد
مره بزمانك صدقك انك مسيحي بيطلعوا
بيقولوا لنا ذمي ولا انتم الذميه اللي
ناسي فلسطين منه مسيح مين ما كان يكون
بطرك بابا خوري شماس اسبوع الميلاد تزامن
مع ذكرى ميلاد الطفله الشهيده ريم او روح
الروح وهي نفس ذكرى ميلاد جدها ايضا فارسل
نشطاء من جميع انحاء العالم بطاقات معايده
بالصوت والصوره عسى ان يلتفت تجار السلاح
والدماء الدوليون الى ماساه الاطفال في
[موسيقى]
غزه ع ميلاد سعيد
ياال
[موسيقى]
لالو اليبه خالد وريم سنه حلوه يا خالد
ريم اخيرا نيكي هايلي مرشحه هايله لرئاسه
امريكا اما
هانها فقد استحق جائزه المفتش كورمبو
عندما اكتشفت الدليل الدامغ على اداره
روسيا طوفان الاقصى الفلسطيني ضد اسرائيل
فطوفان انطلق في السابع من اكتوبر وهو عيد
ميلاد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين نيكي
هايلي من اصل هندي لكن الافلام الهنديه
بريئه من
[موسيقى]
اكتشافها
ختاما سال القاضي اسد الصحراء عمر المختار
هل حاربت الدوله الايطاليه هل شجعت الناس
على محاربتها وهل انت مدرك عقوبه ما فعلت
كل اجاباته كانت نعم اقرارا بحق شعبه
بمقاومه الاحتلال هل انت نادم على ما فعلت
يسال القاضي وهو يعلم سلفا جواب النفي
لشيخ الاحرار الذي لا يندم ابدا على
فضيله هل تدرك انك ستعدم نعم فيحاول القاض
في الدقائق الاخيره ان يغريه بعفو عام
مقابل ان يكتب للمجاهدين طلبا بالتوقف عن
المقاومه فينظر اليه عمر ويقول كلمته
السهيره ان السبابه التي تشهد في كل صلاه
ان لا اله الا الله وان محمدا رسول الله
لا يمكن ان تكتب باطله فكان الحكم
بالاعدام الى اللقاء حكمنا عليك عمر
المختار بالاعدام شنقا امام
الناس في بلده سلوك في الساعه الحاد عش
غدا الس 16س عش من سبتمبر
1931 السنه
التاسعه من العهد
الفاشق انا
لله وانا اليه
[موسيقى]
لراجعون ell